ce qui concerne les québécois alors
regardons faisons le bilan tout de suite
de la fiscalité au québec
quand on parle des recettes fiscales
c'est ce qu'on verse au gouvernement
fédéral au gouvernement du québec en
impôts font aussi la régie des rentes
notamment total de 169 milliards 169
milliards c'est le total des recettes
fiscales qui était prévu au québec par
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
ces 9 milliards de plus qu'en 2010 est
donc même s'il ya des réductions
fiscales
l'économie croît le pib plus importants
et les recettes fiscales augmentent donc
9 milliards de plus une croissance de 5
points 8 % des recettes collectées au
québec par l'ensemble des
administrations publiques
là on peut voir aussi qu'ils collectent
ces sommes-là près d'un dollar surtout
retourne au gouvernement du québec un
peu moins du tiers au gouvernement
fédéral les collectivités locales et le
régime des rentes récolte 9% chacun dont
l'activité locale sur les taxes
foncières essentiellement celles et taxe
foncière des municipalités
alors ça c'est le découpage de des
recettes fiscales qui sont versés par
les contribuables et par les entreprises
tout à fait également mis qui retourne
au gouvernement sous forme d'impôts et
taxes prélèvements obligatoires et si on
parle depuis le 2008 c'était le cru dans
le fond c'est l'année où la fiscalité a
été la plus faible des 18 20 dernières
années
ouais et là il y avait eu des baisses
des pouilles à ce moment là il ya eu la
grande récession les gouvernements on a
parlé d' austérité mais le gouvernement
est obligé d'augmenter les impôts et
taxes pour retrouver l'équilibré et là
on voit que d'année en année après année
le poids augmente on peut être surpris
parce que dans le fond au cours des deux
puits 2015 le gouvernement fédéral avait
réduit le deuxième taux le gouvernement
du québec avait réduit le premier taux
des barèmes d'imposition ont augmenté le
montant personnel de base aboli la
contribution santé
malgré tout ça se reflète pas dans notre
indicateur principal pour le moment le
poids est un peu plus élevé qu'il ne
l'était avant les dernières années et
monsieur couillard et monsieur legault
disent qu'ils baissent nos impôts qui
ont baissé nos charges fiscales mais les
notions la pression augmente c'est ça
mais pour monsieur legault ont valu 800
chance parce que ça doit être le
prochain bateau où les prochains breton
va pouvoir l'évaluer
mais ça veut dire que même effectivement
pour le gouvernement carlos leitao mai
philippe couillard malgré les efforts de
réduire le fardeau qu'il faut dire qu'il
ya plusieurs administrations qui sont si
les municipalités augmente le poids puis
que les gouvernements des provinces
diminue peut-être ça se reflète pas
aussi bien
mais dans l'ensemble des administrations
il n'y a pas de baisse la fiscalité pour
le moment a observé ça c'est le québec
depuis l'an 2000
oui on place le québec à l'intérieur de
l'os et des ouais il y en a beaucoup ici
l'homme yayi à 35 36 pays et 6 piles
ocde on a inséré le québec comme une
administration publique avec les
prélèvements fédéraux provinciaux et des
ensembles et on voit que le québec à
36,8 et au dessus de la moyenne de
l'oscd haut au dessus de la moyenne du
g7 dans le tiers supérieur des pays
comparés le canada on a fait le canada
sans le québec parce exceptionnel le
québec tire le canada vers le haut en
effet le canada salle québec
eux ils se retrouvent dans le tiers
inférieur du poids de la fiscalité
on a nos voisins américains 24% qui se
retrouve 4e avant derniers au quatrième
promis pour la faiblesse du poids de la
fiscalité et szalai inclus cela la
réforme du président entre hommes que
vraiment réduire la fiscalité de 2,5
points de pourcentage en une seule année
2010 est par rapport à 2018 donc des
changements quand même assez fort et
pour une deuxième année consécutive
la palme revient à la france pour le
poids de la fiscalité le plus élevé dans
l'ensemble des pays de l'oci 2e
devançant des pays scandinaves où on dit
souvent que c'est l'autre la fiscalité
la plus élevée mais pour une deuxième
année consécutive c'est en france et au
québec d'ailleurs la fiscalité est élevé
à cause des impôts comme les pays
scandinaves ou et moins des taxes à la
consommation toutefois c'est ça donc au
québec ce qui explique ces ça comme on
disait c'est l'impôt sur le revenu qui
est plus important un peu moins un peu
moins les taxes
donc il faut il faut garder ça il faut
garder ça à l'esprit quand on regarde
les changements et on mise de plus en
plus sur les taxes sur l'essence en sur
la pollution
vous en avez parlé un petit peu on vous
a préparé un autre graphique qui ne
montrent les taxes appliquées sur
l'essence
à vrai dire c'est qu'on dit cette année
ça va être le plat bientôt va être
déposé le plan d'électrification et des
changements climatiques on s'est dit
pourquoi pas ajoutez des indicateurs
d'écotaxe dans notre bilan est là on a
pris les écotaxes qui sont non pas la
tps et la tvq mais qui sont la taxe
6 fédérale sur l'essence la taxe
spécifique du québec sur l'essence et le
fameux la fameuse bourse la de prix du
carbone le spectre qui inclut qui ajoute
des taxes sur l'essence et donc on a
calculé ça en proportion du prix du
litre de l'essence hors taxes et sava
présente au québec 41,5 pour cent du
prix hors taxe l'équivalent des textes
on trouve aussi beaucoup on trouve quand
on va à la pompe que c'est élevé mais
bon on s'aperçoit ya une magie loyer de
pays que les tak sont plus importantes
que le prix hors taxe donc le royaume
uni par exemple les écotaxes représente
150% du prix de avant taxes la vente
c'est donc ce sera énorme au québec
c'est 41 puis en ontario et 33 pc ça et
ça nous deux donne est pour l'heure plus
l'ontario et le québec ça des données
plus récentes pour 2018 et on note par
contre il n'ya pas les états unis donc
dans l'ide comparaison de l' ocde les
états unis n'étaient pas là donc on n'a
pas pu les comparer alors voyez que
beaucoup d'informations si vous allez
sur le site de la chaire de recherche de
l'université de sherbrooke vous allez
pouvoir voir d'ailleurs tous ces
graphiques qui sont là qui sont
disponibles et vous allez pouvoir les
voir de plus près une chose à surveiller
en 2020 bon en 2020 il ya eu des
élections fédérales gouvernement
minoritaire mais ont néanmoins promis
d'assujettir à la tps le commerce
électronique donc ça pourrait être à
surveiller du côté fédéral ce côté
québec se dire malgré les surplus qui
sont en partie conjoncturelle
jusqu'à quel point le ministre
conservateur et faire des changements
les premières savoir faire des
modifications fiscales qui ne seront pas
dans les promesses qui avaient été
faites initialement donc c'est ce qui
serait assez d'avoir merci beaucoup lui
gbagbo
y'a pas de quoi revoir